qui a dit non seulement Jésus-Christ
était fils de Dieu
mais il était d'excellente famille du
côté de sa mère c'est étonnant non
alors on va faire la culture ensemble
encore une fois ce soir puisque c'est
alors je crois qu'on pourrait vraiment
marquer tout de suite et dire que
c'était mission est une émission hyper
culturelle et qu'on va exhiber vos
connaissances alors vous demande de
faire un petit jeu de citation entre Guy
Bedos et Pierre Desproges qui nous ont
choisi un certain nombre de textes je
voudrais me faire une déclaration
limitée
sur la Pologne c'est très difficile de
faire les gugus suite après mais enfin
le problème d'humoriste français ne sont
rien à côté de ceux des humoristes
polonais ce soir on peut rire on peut
rire pas à propos de la Pologne mais
pour essayer d'exorciser la trouille de
la guerre qu'on en a c'est bien ce que
j'aime bien c'est pas mal une feuille de
sel
ça me fait rire
aux enterrements d'ailleurs
on essaye ce petit jeu
[Musique]
d'explications programmant
j'aurais dû demander à Monsieur Brice
son anniversaire
pour les 75 bougies
les citations d'ailleurs
sans la liberté de blâmer il n'est point
de Loches flatteur elle est dure
journal de droite
c'était une époque de liberté où on
emmerdait pas systématiquement les gens
avec deux droites il est pas bien vilain
etc de gauche il est beau
de le dire et rédacteur en chef et
critique au Quotidien de Paris bon nous
reviendrons tout à l'heure alors
pour en finir avec la Pologne
qui a dit qui a écrit en Pologne la
démocratie est populaire l'armée
populaire il n'y a que le peuple qui ne
soit pas populaire
il faut que je dise non c'est récent ça
ce matin
[Musique]
c'est de gauche ou de droite
allez la réponse Dominique
de ton ce matin je trouve que c'est une
très belle chose
le rire et le propre de l'homme elle est
dure
les femmes c'est comme les pommes de
terre il faut que ça saute
on les a pas vu encore
[Musique]
il ne suffit pas
il ne suffit pas d'être heureux encore
faut-il que les autres soient malheureux
ça c'est bien du renard
et plus le mettre estompe le chien
fidèle
c'est non
de son Antonio de Frédéric Dard
il faut vivre pour manger et non pas
manger pour vivre ça c'est
dans les bouffeuses ridicules
[Rires]
introuvable les Arabes c'est comme les
Juifs ça s'attrape par la mer
mais c'est très dur c'est pas c'est pas
trop favorable c'est un oriental
tu ne seras rien
tu as beau faire tu ne seras rien faut
faire un autre chant sur lui là
tu comprends les plus grands poètes les
plus profonds prosateurs mais bien qu'on
prétendent que comprendre cette égalé tu
leur seras aussi peu comparable qu'un
infime
peut l'être à des géants c'est pas de
Léon Blois adresser Victor Hugo
qui a dit non seulement Jésus-Christ
était fils de Dieu
mais il était d'excellente famille du
côté de sa mère
[Musique]
c'est étonnant non